to upload wireframes JPEGs or PNG's
simply drag and drop your images
directly into your browser window or you
can simply click browse to select
screens you'd like to import if you find
yourself manually up loading screens one
by one it may be a long and cumbersome
process so you may consider it using
envision sync as a method for
automatically uploading your screens for
you envision sync can automatically
detect changes to the screens that
you've saved on a local folder on your
computer and automatically import those
into envision for you the advantage of
using envision sync is that you can
automatically have those screens
uploaded into envision so you don't have
to manually upload them each time you
want to create a project once you've
finished uploading your screens you'll
see a thumbnail preview of all of your
screens uploaded into your project